chez les adolescents est ce que le
vaccin paf either est efficace qu'est ce
qu'on a comme document qui nous
permettent d'évaluer l'efficacité du
trailer chez les adolescents écoutez on
n'a rien oui quand je dis rien à rien
sinon des rapports de l'industriel aux
médias comment voulez vous que des
scientifiques évaluent un vaccin
correctement dans une population
spécifique
s'ils n'ont pas les documents
indispensables à ce travail
donc aujourd'hui on est dans cette année
aujourd'hui exactement dans cette
problématique
pas de données comment voulez-vous
conclure comment on va t'on évaluer la
contagiosité comment va-t-on évalué que
la vaccination des adolescents va
diminuer la contagiosité vert vers l'est
vers les les autres on va dire ça les
hôtes hier le principe du vaccin
altruiste n'y a pas de démonstration
scientifique on pourrait le faire on
aurait pu le faire mais on l'a pas fait
exactement comme les essais cliniques
avec le vaccin de pfizer
on aurait pu très bien travaillé on
aurait pu attendre un peu on aurait pu
faire du double aveugle
on aurait pu confier l'essai clinique à
des investigateurs qui ne soient pas des
employés du sponsor ouailles un peu le
conflit d'intérêts ce sont les employés
du sponsor tir de taser qui conduisent
l'étude tout leur intérêt
évidemment c'est que ça marche c'est
leur salaire c'est leur carrière c'est
leur avenir c'est leur ambition et c'est
donc ça s'éteint c'est un biais
tellement majeur qu'il est
incompréhensible que personne ne le voit
mais je sais que beaucoup le voient mais
surtout que personne ne le disent il
faut arrêtez donc de prendre les données
d'observation comme des données
définitif et on a été je pense au cours
des derniers mois tellement déçu avec
tous ces experts qui circulent sur les
plateaux de télé des professeurs des
universitaires des académiciens je ne
cite personne mais qu'ils se sont
trompés à chaque fois
[Musique]